leur sauvetage s'annonce long et
périlleux il faudra plusieurs mois en
effet pour sortir les 33 hommes bloqués
dans une mine au chili
le contact a pu être établi grâce à une
sonde envoyée 700 mètres sous terre
une micro-caméra ensuite pu capter les
images de ces hommes pris au piège
depuis plus de deux semaines maintenant
et sharbini des larmes de joie après 17
jours d'angoissé
les sauveteurs exulte ils viennent de
découvrir à l'extrémité de cette sonde
quelques mots écrits à l'encré rouge de
la main de l'un des mineurs en plus vu
une preuve de vie inespéré et c'est le
président chilien en personne qui lit le
message devant les caméras cette lettre
est sortie aujourd'hui du coeur de la
montagne elle dit il nous allons bien
chacun des 33 d'entre nous nous sommes
allés puis les sauveteurs découvrent
cette image presque irréelle le visage
d'un homme apparemment en bonne santé
l'un des 33 mineurs pour obtenir cette
vidéo
ils ont fait descendre à 700 mètres de
profondeur une micro caméra dans un
conduit d'appel 60 cm de diamètre
pour les familles qui campaient aux
abords du site dans la tente d'un signe
c'est le soulagement
nous n'avons jamais perdu espoir je
faisais partie des gens qui les savait
vivent depuis le début pour autant les
33 hommes ne sont pas tirés d'affaires
le puits principal est trop instable
pour les remonter
il faudra creuser un second passage
l'opération pourrait prendre plusieurs
mois au fond de la mine
la température dépasse de 35 degrés les
mineurs seront approvisionnés depuis la
surface et suivies par des psychologues
par téléphone
les 33 mineurs chiliens bloqués dans
leur mine depuis trois semaines
maintenant ne sont pas prêts de
retrouver l'air libre
prochainement il faudra certainement
plusieurs semaines et même plusieurs
mois pour les remonter le temps de
creuser un tunnel pour les atteindre
en revanche les premières images de ces
hommes coincés 700 mètres sous terre ont
pu être diffusées des images qui bien
sûr ont ému les chiliens commentaires
sarah benhaida une vise envoyé à tous
les chiliens depuis leur refuge 700 m
sous terre les 33 mineurs toujours
bloqués lance un message à leurs
compatriotes sur cette vidéo qu'ils ont
tourné eux-mêmes bonjour à ma soeur à
mon père et à tout le monde
merci de ne pas nous avoir abandonnés on
sait tous ce que vous faites pour nous
ils se disent prêts à affronter les
trois ou quatre longs mois d'attentes
avant d'être libéré ils ont déjà
organisé le rationnement en eau et en
nourriture et ils ont même trouvé des
activités pour occuper le temps comme ce
jeu de dominos 700 mètres dessus de leur
tête le forage d'un tunnel pour les
extraire va bientôt commencer dimanche
ou lundi
en attendant leur seul lien avec la
surface de la terre
ce sont ces tuyaux qui acheminent des
vivres des médicaments ou des messages
depuis 22 jours maintenant les familles
qui campent sur place sont soulagés de
voir les visages de leurs proches
mais elles attendent des explications le
5 août un éboulement obstruent la mine
les 33 hommes auraient pu s'échapper par
le conduit de ventilation mais la
compagnie qui les emploient n'avait pas
prévu d'échelle pourtant obligatoire
fermé en 2007 après un accident mortel
7000 n'aurait pas dû rouvrir selon les
familles qui porte plainte
ils gagnent des fortunes sur le dos des
mineurs qui ne sont même pas protégés
tout ce que l'on demande c'est qu'il
paye ce qu'il nous doit
le gouvernement chilien a fait appel à
la nasa les conditions de vie au fond de
la mine de san josé serait comparable à
celle des astronautes enfermés plusieurs
mois dans des stations spatiales
mais d'abord ces images elles ont jailli
à la surface de la mine chilienne comme
un éclatant signal d'espoir à 700 m sous
terre la vie des 33 mineurs coincés
depuis 21 jours s'organise
ils ont reçu des vivres ainsi qu'une
caméra vidéo ils peuvent désormais
montrer à leurs proches et aux
sauveteurs
à quoi ressemble leur quotidien dorothée
olliéric ce sont des premières images du
groupe de mineurs pris au piège à 700 m
sous terre et on voit des hommes
détendu organisé presque serein
j'embrasse ma femme mes parents mes
frères tout le monde je pense à mariana
on sera très vite dehors je l'espère cet
homme à la barbe blanche entame une
visite guidée du refuge il montre le
point à pharmacie équipé d'alcool de
médicaments et de dentifrice envoyés par
les secours
là dit il c'est le coin où nous nous
divertissons les mineurs ont bricolé un
jeu de dominos le refuge ne dépasse pas
50 mètres carrés mais des galeries
peuvent encore être empruntée avec des
anges toujours utilisés par les mineurs
les hommes semblent dans une phase
d'euphorie qu'ils entonnent souvent
l'hymne national même s'ils savent
qu'ils devront attendre pour être
secouru peut-être un mois peut-être 3
les familles qui ont pu visionner la
totalité de la vidéo de 45 minutes sont
rassurés quand un ils sont contents ils
ont le moral
il chante un salut leurs familles et
leurs épouses leurs enfants ils sont
vraiment bien mais tvn cela dit il va
falloir préserver la santé physique et
mentale des 33 mineurs
et pour ça des experts de la nasa
spécialiste en confinement dans l'espace
devraient arriver sur zone des
astronautes ou encore des sous mariniers
vont également prodigué des conseils aux
mines
quant aux ravitaillements il est en
train de se roder grâce à ses tubes
d'acier descendu par un étroit conduit
toutes les 30 minutes dans les
profondeurs de la mine nourris soignés
les mineurs semble prêt à poursuivre
l'épreuve d'autant plus qu'ils sont un
pays entier derrière eux
tout ne va pas si bien pour les 33
mineurs chiliens bloqués depuis 22 jours
à 700 m sous terre la première vidéo les
montré hier en forme optimiste mais cinq
d'entre eux souffrent de dépression
annoncée hier soir le gouvernement
chilien les opérations de sauvetage
elles débuteront demain ou lundi que
jean gilbert malgré la détermination et
les sourires affichés
certains des 33 mineurs chiliens coincés
sous la terre commence à perdre le moral
sur cette vidéo diffusée il ya deux
jours seule la moitié d'entre eux
apparaît les autres souffrent de
dépression après plus de trois semaines
par 35 degrés à 700 mètres de profondeur
les secours ont déjà organisé pour cinq
mineurs d entretien à distance avec un
psychiatre marie laure ce sont les plus
isolées ils n'ont pas voulu apparaître
sur la vidéo il ne s'alimentent pas bien
aujourd'hui nous allons nous concentrer
sur ma dépression est le terme qui
convient
grâce aux vivres et eau médicaments
acheminés par une sonde
leur état général s'est néanmoins
améliorée au dessus d'eux à l'air libre
les proches s'installe pour une longue
attente entre espoir et résignation
c'est désespérant de ne rien pouvoir
faire pour eux on exprime tous tout
sentiment pour on veut les aider à
garder la foi elle me demande de
vérifier que sa fille s'est lassé de
voir il s'inquiète beaucoup pour elle
il m'a demandé de l'épouser et j'ai dit
oui les mineurs captifs vont bénéficier
des conseils d'experts de la nasa
habitué au confinement dans l'espace
mais pour cet homme d'église c'est aussi
la foi qui sauve g33 bible le renvoyer
par la sonde elles pour leur apporter un
soutien spirituel
les travaux de sauvetage commenceront
vraiment demain ou lundi
un excavateur de 30 tonnes doit forer un
conduit de 700 m de long et 66 cm de
large
il faudra attendre trois ou quatre mois
avant de pouvoir extraire les mineurs de
leur piège souterrain
actualité à l'étranger avec d'abord
cette incroyable tentative de sauvetage
qui captive l'amérique du sud et
l'amérique tout entière 33 mineurs vous
le savez sont coincés sous terre les uns
sur les autres
depuis près d'un mois les opérations ont
commencé aujourd'hui mais elle ne
devrait pas aboutir avant la mi décembre
lionel feierstein ils sont fatigués mais
tiéné debout filmé hier matin grâce à
l'envoi d'une petite caméra
les 33 mineurs coincés à 700 m sous
terre garde le moral
j'envoie une pensé à ma femme que
j'adore à toute ma famille à mes cousins
maison que qui nous attendent on essaye
de s'organiser et charme aux collègues à
sa nourriture ici qu'il n'a pas encore
mangé j'ai trouvé là vous voyez on a des
boissons énergisantes
au moins on est tous bien m'hydrater
c'est ce qu'on voulait les mineurs sont
confinés dans ses galeries où l'humidité
avoisine les 95 % et la chaleur 30
degrés il occupe une pièce de 50 mètres
carrés où il partage la nourriture
la plupart d'or sur les sièges des
camions de chantier situé dans
d'immenses qualités à l'extérieur du
local
le groupe s'est réparti les tâches
sécuriser les galeries charger les
batteries des lampes ou s'occuper de
l'infirmerie
hier pour la première fois en 24 jours
les mineurs ont pu parler à leurs
proches des conversations d'une minute
par radio téléphone
je suis contente je suis très contente
de l'avoir entendue comment va-t-il il
va bien il est en forme pour soutenir le
moral des mineurs les autorités leur ont
envoyé des lecteurs mp3 consoles de jeux
et projecteur vidéo les films ont été
sélectionnés par des psychologues
côté santé des vaccins ont été descendus
dans ses tuyaux notamment contre le
tétanos la diphtérie et la grippe
évidemment dans la mine les risques de
maladies respiratoires très élevé et
nous faisons tout notre possible pour
les prévenir
le groupe vient de quitter son premier
refuge pour une galerie plus sèches et
sécurisée d'une centaine de mètres
l'énorme foreuse de 38 tonnes doit
d'ailleurs commencer dans quelques
heures a creusé dans sa direction
un puits de secours de 702 m ensuite les
mineurs devront se glisser un par un
dans une nacelle mais ce travail
fastidieux pourrait durer deux à trois
mois
le chili cherche mais n'a toujours pas
trouvé d'autre moyen plus rapide de
sauver ces mineurs
au chili cette fois les travaux de
forage vont débuter pour tenter
d'extraire les 33 mineurs coincés depuis
presque un mois à 700 mètres sous terre
leur attente sera longue au moins trois
mois certains commencent déjà à craquer
et pour les aider à supporter cet
enfermement les secours multiplient les
échanges avec leurs familles lianhai
feierstein elle était attendue comme le
messie
la strata 950 c'est énorme foreuse de 30
tonnes devrait dans quelques heures
commencé à creuser le trou de dégagement
quinze à vingt mètres par jour peut être
plus en attendant à 700 mètres de
profondeur
les 33 mineurs chiliens bloqués essaye
de garder le moral
j'envoie une pensé à ma femme que
j'adore à toute ma famille à mes cousins
maison que qui nous attendent on essaye
de s'organiser et charme aux collègues à
sa nourriture ici qu'il n'a pas encore
manger là vous voyez on a des boissons
énergisantes
au moins on est tous bien hydratée c'est
ce qu'on voulait hier pour la première
fois les proches des mineurs on tue le
droit de communiquer directement avec
eux une minute par famille je suis
contente je suis très contente de
l'avoir entendue comment va-t-il
il va bien il est en forme et ma mère
selon les autorités les cinq mineurs qui
souffrait de problèmes de dépression
semble aller mieux tout le groupe a
déménagé dans un endroit plus sec de la
mine côté santé des médecins ont fait
passer par ces tuyaux des vaccins
notamment contre le tétanos et la
diphtérie
hier le pape s'est adressé en espagnol
aux mineurs et aux familles souhaitant
qu'ils gardent leur sérénité
cette excellence ça nous fait beaucoup
de bien
la fois nous est vraiment de la foi et
beaucoup de patience les autorités
chiliennes ne s'attendent pas remonter
les mineurs avant deux ou trois mois
donc dans les jours qui viennent
regagner la surface les 33 mineurs
chiliens de ce procès sont tenus au
courant heure par heure de l'avancée des
travaux sur ce puits qui les a rejoint
hier avant de prendre la direction du
chili où les familles de mineurs
retiennent déjà leur souffle voyons
comment les opérations de secours vont
réellement se dérouler explications
dorothée olliéric le jour j se rapproche
si vite chacun fait son film sa
chronique d'un sauvetage annoncé de leur
côté les autorités chiliennes veulent
planifier les moindres détails
il faut tout d'abord préparé le terrain
c'est-à-dire sécuriser le passage de
cette nacelle dans le puits de secours
l'objectif est de souder ses tubes
d'acier comme cela pour gainer les
parois deuxième étape
l'extraction avec la descente à 622 m
sous terre d'un infirmier mais aussi
d'un expert en sauvetage minier pour
préparer physiquement et
psychologiquement les mineurs à leur
évacuation
le sauvetage en lui-même pourrait
prendre un jour et demi à raison d'une
heure pour la remontée de chaque mineur
la sortie des 33 hommes doit se faire
selon des procédures connues des
sauveteurs du monde entier on va sortir
les mineurs dans un ordre bien précis
d'abord les plus habiles qui pourront
faire face à n'importe quel imprévu puis
les plus faibles et en dernier les plus
forts
les mineurs seront examinés par des
médecins dès leur sortie
après deux mois passés sous terre ils
devront porter des lunettes spéciales
pour éviter les lésions oculaires
notamment en remontant à la surface
rapidement les mineurs pourront partager
un premier moment d'intimité avec leurs
familles dans ses frais tabriquet
installé sur le site de la mine de san
josé ils auront ici un contact intime et
prolongé avec leur famille avant l'étape
suivante où ils prendront en hélicoptère
aurait pu transporter vers l'hôpital
un millier de journalistes sont attendus
pour le happy end
les mineurs ont même été rapidement
formés aux techniques de communication
et d'un terrain
bienvenue dans ce journal c'est l'image
du jour on craignait de découvrir des
rescapés malades ou diminuer bien ce
sont des hommes en pleine santé
débordant de vie qui sont remontés à la
surface au chili
une prouesse technique une grande scène
de communion nationale aussi voici ces
images elles sont commentés par dorothée
olliéric personne ne voulait remonter en
premier pour ne pas voler la vedette aux
autres nouvelles manches et florencio
avalos 31 ans qui a été désigné sophis
byron ne peut retenir ses larmes s'est
levé par les applaudissements des
sauveteurs
le mineur sort calmement des gestes de
tendresse après une épreuve de 69 22
mètres sous terre le monde entier voit
en direct le deuxième mineur pénétrer
dans l'étroite capsule phénix la
remontée dure 15 minutes
chaque article mario on t'attend marion
et reste plus beaucoup merci les amis
merci
les pousses du mineur est agréablement
surprise en entendant les cris de joie
de son mât qui arriva
mario sepulveda débordant d'énergie sort
des pierres rapporte et du fond de la
lune cadeau souvenir pour les sauveteurs
et pour le président chinois byd ensuite
vers ses amis mineurs
dopé par la liberté retrouvée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
extravagant et extravertie celui qu'on
appelle déjà super mario est un mineur
qui pense à son travail avec humilité
qu'on a mis dans cette épreuve notre
folie nos coeurs de mineurs et toute
notre expérience professionnelle demain
il faudra de vrais changements pour ceux
qui travaillent dans les mines des
améliorations on ne peut pas rester
comme ça les heures passent
la mine se vident les sauvetages se
suivent mais ne se ressemblent pas à
travers ce puits de secours filmé depuis
la nacelle et après les plus agiles ce
sont les plus faibles qui retrouvait
parmi les 33 mineurs un bolivien que le
président evo morales est venu féliciter
en personne le chef d'état bolivien a
également remercié son homologue chili
pour sebastian pinera s'est aussi
l'unité du pays qui est célébré
aujourd'hui on à l'hôtel qu'elle a dit
on avec une nuit où la vie a été plus
que la mort où l'espérance a triomphé de
l'angoissé la note qu'elle entame qui
nous fait sentir davantage comme des
êtres humains des frères unis dans la
force la volonté le courage est prêt à
affronter ce que nous réserve le futur à
les balades
c'est d'ailleurs tout un pays qui a
passé une nuit blanche et les chiliens
n'ont pas fini de fêter le sauvetage des
les mineurs de fond devenu héros
mais d'abord les pilotes au chili tous
les mineurs ont retrouvé l'air libre
le dernier à sortir est en quelque sorte
le chef de l'équipe des trente trois
reportages franck jeunes aux autres
hissant le braz une dernière accolade
avec les secouristes et louis sol soit
embarque dans la nacelle phénix en
surface les familles n'ont jamais chanté
aussi fort 622 mètres de remontée et
celui que les 33 surnomme le capitaine
retrouve la liberté
le chef de quart luis urzua vient
d'arriver en très bonne condition
physique
c'est l'ultime étape d'un sauvetage
historique au bord des larmes le
président chilien s'avance pour
l'embrasser
vous avez été un bon chef dans le camp
espérant que ça c'est une explosion de
joie
la fin du calvaire
les mineurs sont tous sains et saufs
luis ochoa se fait alors le porte parole
des 33 j'espère que ça n'arrivera plus
jamais je suis fier de mon pays et je
remercie tout le monde
les secouristes et tous ceux qui ont
oeuvré pour nous vive le chili dans la
nuit
l'ambulance qui le transporte à
l'hôpital a bien du mal à se frayer un
chemin au milieu de la liesse populaire
le capitaine va y retrouver tous ses
camarades pour 48 heures d'examens
médicaux
selon les médecins les 33 sont dans une
forme étonnante à tel point que les
autorités ont décidé d'écourter le
séjour à l'hôpital de certains d'entre
eux dans quelques heures deux ou trois
mineurs seront donc autorisés à rentrer
chez eux
et ce après 69 jours passés sous terre
au chili ont fait le retour à la vie
normale des 33 mineurs bloqués sous
terre pendant 69 jours ici à copiapo
on célèbre comme il se doit le retour
chez lui du mineur le plus âgé mario
gomez 63 ans
tout va bien et moi bien je suis très
ému c'est normal tous se précipitent
dans la petite maison familiale pour
féliciter embrasser effleuré mario gomez
son épouse elle ne s'attendait pas à une
telle ferveur
je suis très touché 13 et lui aussi je
ne m'attendais pas à une si belle
réception pour lui dans une autre maison
du village ces mêmes scènes de liesse de
ferveur de joie qui se répète ici chez
cet autre mineur ariel ticona avec son
fils dans les bras
il est accueilli en véritable héros
[Applaudissements]
je vais bien je récupère je suis avec
mes amis les voisins et toute la famille
toujours dans ce petit village de
copiapo
cette même ferveur et émotion chez un
autre enfant du pays victor segovia
durant les deux mois passés sous terre
il a noirci des feuilles de papier pour
raconter son expérience j'ai écrit pour
mes amis et pour ma famille sur les 33
mineurs du puits de san jose seuls deux
d'entre eux devront encore patienter
quelques heures avant de pouvoir faire
la fête
il souffre de vertiges et de maux de
tête
c'est la première fois qu'il revienne à
la mine quelques-uns des 33 mineurs
miraculés du chili se sont retrouvés
avec leurs familles aujourd'hui pour y
célébrer leur retour à l'air libre
c'est une joie d'être libre je suis si
heureux d'être de retour ici et je
remercie le seigneur voulait revenir et
voir cet endroit où ma famille
maintenant une cérémonie religieuse
devait avoir lieu pour marquer
symboliquement la fin de ce calvaire de
69 jours passés sous terre
le président chilien a promis par
ailleurs de renforcer la sécurité dans
les mines du pays